hey guys welcome to ask IJ from Madrid
intro please Malu Thank You Jenna for
that wonderful Spanish rendition of my
ask IG intro for those of you watching
my vlogs and following my tweets you
know that I just got back from Spain
which brings me to my first question
Twitter question
Jed's aunt wants to know why did I go to
Spain I was in Madrid for a Ford Focus
global test drive and let me just tell
you I can't even explain to you how
awesome it was not only was Madrid
wonderful but I got to race some cars
full power right to the floor right to
the floor break our break our third
power now full power keep to the right
hand side right and by race I may not
really race but sort of race considering
an extremely slow driver to me this was
racing around this ball off the gas and
brake turn now turn right and just as a
joke
I registered youtube.com slash iJustine
Racing I'm gonna post all of the videos
from the in-car cameras on that channel
if you feel like checking him out click
there nicosia wants to know what my
favorite Spanish word is and if you guys
have watched any of my videos previously
you'll know that my favorite Spanish
word is biblioteca I know that's not
because I like to go to the library it's
just for some reason the only Spanish
word that I really ever can remember
Carter wants to know if I learned any
new Spanish words as a matter of fact I
did probably one of my job phrases was
no espanol
and then KSS day because I didn't know
what anything was right now quiero dog a
comida ahora mismo
I'd like to know how I deal with
traveling through all the time zones
actually this is the first time that
I've really traveled outside of the
country so dealing with the time zone
change has been pretty difficult
basically I've just been sleeping a lot
and drinking a lot of coffee so far
that's sort of worked and that is also
ask you what I was doing in Spain and as
I said I was driving cars right yeah go
to well go well you probably want to
reverse park is there asks something
that I don't really know what you said
ething was to know why I'm not following
John Cena and actually I am following
John Cena wanax
is asking what I was like in high school
was I inert was I the preppy girl ah
jeez do you guys think the nerd
obviously Facebook question
Chaz mass where is the library I
actually don't know where the library is
alonzo Jordan asks how many subscribers
I had when I first started on YouTube
and obviously I didn't have any add none
zero so when you first start how are you
gonna get any subscribers when you first
joined you don't zero I see zero in
Spanish don't know Kyle Todd wants to
know what I'm gonna visit England and if
I have a Nintendo DS actually yes I do
have a Nintendo DS and I'm looking
forward to getting a 3ds sometime soon
and as far as England I don't really
have any set plans right now but I would
like to come visit you guys they sir
wants to know if I had to create a
cupcake what kind of decoration would I
put on the cupcake well the decoration
that I would try to not put on it
wouldn't be a fire a flame because I
probably would put the cupcakes in the
oven and it probably catch on fire I am
such awful cook Joshua wants to know how
I'm gonna handle not having his sheets
in Spain now supposedly that don't know
which chooses it's my favourite gas
station back in my busy Pittsburgh now
there's no shoots in LA so obviously
I've been managing quite well let me
tell you what else I have had the best
coffee and espresso that I've ever had
in Spain in my entire life I'm
considering relocating what's my
favorite attachment for the floss first
and foremost the red dot and if I have
warlord on then I would probably choose
the suppressor oh the flamethrower
all he wants me to do some Spanish
dancing or go to a bullfight well I'm
not really gonna dance for you because
you guys see me dancing all the time I'm
not gonna go to a bullfight but what I
did do is buy a bull in the airport for
you guys so if you want this leave a
comment below saying give me the bowl
Diana wants to know if I like mashed
potatoes yeah Jurek was asking me if I
had any more plans than just hanging out
in Spain and I wish that I did the sadly
I was only there for a few days but I
did get to see a few cool things
Wow the guy knew dos dos Manos what's
that mean
those men dailybooth questions Batman
spider-man or Superman Superman
I think jaylen Johnson is asking
something about his boogers in Spanish
next question if I wanted to use a
blackberry I've actually never really
had the urge to use a blackberry since I
love my iPhone but I would like to use
bbm sometimes so here that's where all
the cool kids are doing
bbm me baby and how about I am a mess
and I am a mess my tweet you I had a bbm
but I probably would get a blackberry on
Verizon or some other network as opposed
to AT&T so I could actually make phone
calls since that's what phones are
supposed to do did somebody miss the
memo 18 did you guys forget that cell
phones phones hi hello I'd like to
sometimes talk on it like to talk on it
medicine earth wants to know if I've
ever tried rapping in Spanish actually I
can't rap in English so rapping in
Spanish would be just as much of as a
stir as probably more so of a disaster
than an English was my favorite place
that I've traveled to well considering
you haven't really left the country very
much other than this past trip to Madrid
Hawaii is probably one of my top
favorites big bad John is asking me a
question in Spanish and good thing for
Google Translate because you're asking
me something about going to college
today today go to college I did I went
to a two-year school pti Pittsburgh
Technical Institute over there from
let me tell you what and a good freakin
time please put me in your ass guy J
episode comments so if you guys remember
in the last episode I was talking about
the number one comment that I usually
get and that's iJustine please put me in
your ask IG episode so here is the first
official segment of Gesine please put me
in your ask IG episode comments please
fantastic now if you guys would like to
be in the next episode of ask IJ just
leave a comment below saying Justine
please put me in your a scotch episode
and of course this only applies to
YouTube comments so don't go ask them
any other places cuz I'm not gonna be
taking them from there thank you guys so
much for watching this episode don't
forget to leave a comment below if you
want the bowl leave a comment if you
want to be in the next episode of ask IJ
and well OH
subscribe soon know what I launched new
video check out the rest of my youtube
channels here thanks again for watching
and I'm so sad because I'd planned on
shooting this episode while I was in
Madrid I'd started but it was so pulled
out and I was so exhausted that it just
wasn't working out I planned on going
back and trying to shoot it again
but it wasn't there long enough next
time next time my friends alright I'll
see you guys in the next episode of ask
IJ koruna vlog university or wow I'm
just gonna stop talking now okay Shh